[Music]
you think about the effect on airline
activity an airline employment it's not
just the airline it's not just the
employees who work for the airline and
it's not just the employees who work for
the ground service people doing doing
fueling and cleaning the labs on the
ramp you're also talking about the taxi
drivers who are picking up passengers at
the airport and then go a step further
and think about the little sandwich
joint but you don't see that that's at
the taxi pool where the taxi drivers are
waiting to pick up fares and that guy is
the list is down the chain that guy is
losing business too so you just think
about the the web of business that US
airlines are tied to and it just it just
filters all the way through the economy
it's incredible
revenues are going to be down 252
billion this year according to Darryl an
industry group IATA that's just an
estimate and that's that's that's a
number they put out earlier this week
it's more than double an estimate that
they had put out earlier in March and it
could well turn out to be worse because
nobody really knows this is going to go
on
many of those those airlines that
suspended operations or smaller ones but
even now some some of the biggest ones
are virtually shutting down Singapore
with tons of Ryanair our scaling back
operations 95% and just maintaining
service on a few critical routes and in
the u.s. we're headed in that direction
to Italy did halt did halt the flow of
people but almost at the same time the
traffic that the passengers would
otherwise have been flying in and out of
Italy stopped flying anyway so it's
almost like it doesn't matter whether
the whether the halt is driven by
government regulation or by the behavior
of individuals and so we saw already as
the as the as the infection spiked in
Italy the demand started to fall off all
the way across all the way across Europe
and then in response to the demand
falling off the Airlines canceled
flights
American Airlines said said this morning
that there they're gonna expand because
they were claiming they're now going to
be reducing the service 60% in April and
80% in May Delta the strongest airline
in the world by far they're going to be
coming capacity 70% and if there's a
downturn in business travel that would
be very serious for airlines business
travelers cert or their most lucrative
customers you know if you have to if
you're if you have union agreements or
or employment agreements such that
you're gonna have to continue to plant
pay all your employees even as you don't
use them that's 30 percent at 30 35
percent of your costs that don't get
reduced that's that's one that's one
pass that can happen to Airlines and
then you have other other scenarios
where the airlines are actually able to
lay off or furlough those employees so
we're starting to see a resumption and
an uptick of travel in China is coming
back up more slowly than we had seen for
the Recovery Act
the other epidemics and given the given
the breadth and the scale of the way
this the wake of it has affected daily
life and so many people it's not
unreasonable to think that that recovery
that the recovery of activity would take
would take longer but I think it really
is going to depend much more on on the
public policy on how the public policy
plays out rather than on what the
airlines do